all events just are they're unchangeable
they're immutable so the events can't
change and you simply if you go back to
the past are fulfilling the precise set
of events that allowed you to exist and
to go on that journey in the first place
[Music]
this is StarTalk Cosmic queries Edition
and today we're going to be talking
about time travel inspired by Dickens
classic novel A Christmas Carol Chuck
love to have you on this always a
pleasure to be here although I'm not
actually I'm not actually here I'm
coming to you from the future you should
just know that
thanks for that heads up in case that
matters let me say it this way Neil
your kids
thank you Doc Brown
[Laughter]
you realize when they they went into the
year 2015. just thought I'd remind you
of that wow
wow yeah yeah yeah we'll get back to
that so well I know a little bit about
time travel I don't know nearly as much
as our guest which is why we brought him
on a good place and colleague from up
the street at Columbia University Brian
Greene Brian dude our returning Champion
returns
our returning Champion Brian Greene
ladies and gentlemen
professor of of physics and math is that
right both of those yeah that's right
that's right
isn't that wait as a layperson isn't
that redundant it does sound redundant
yeah but I don't touch equipment that's
what it emphasizes oh yeah it's like get
the hell out of the lab you're one of
those theorists
yeah so Brian is a theoretical physicist
and a long time friend and uh it's just
a delight with best-selling books and
let me get the title correct of his
latest book because that that this title
leaves nothing out here it is Until the
End of Time mind matter and our search
for meaning in an evolving Universe came
out last year Brian that's a that title
doesn't leave anything untouched you
need you need all the good search words
so that yeah
that's that's good who's the publisher
of that yeah optimized yeah enough very
nice very nice and of course many people
know you or know of you through being
co-founder uh I think with your wife is
that correct of the world Science
Festival
yeah Tracy day I met Tracy day before I
knew you when she was a news reporter
was it for NBC is that right ABC yeah
ABC yeah yeah she did an interview with
me I didn't know that she never she
never mentioned it
yeah we go way back
so let's put some context on the table
so uh Charles Dickens which is you know
he wrote Oliver he wrote A Tale of Two
Cities he wrote a Christmas I mean he
wrote a bunch of stuff
and I think he wrote A Tale of Two
Cities yeah yeah of course and it was
the best of times amen the worst of
times right now we're we're in the
second part of that right now yes
exactly yeah
so uh written long time ago 1843 and by
some of our by some measures it may be
the first sort of modern literary
example of time travel or the
implications of time travel and so
that's well before like a half a century
before H.G Wells is the time machine so
itself quite a quite a remarkable step
to take in storytelling so
so Brian you know before we had
Einstein's relativity
uh do you know how did anybody think
about time travel yeah it's a good
question what was it missing what what
what what let me say that differently
yeah what what do we in our enlightened
modern times with the benefit of
Relativity get to say about time travel
that they couldn't say before Einstein
before the uh you know 1905 special
relativity paper and the 1916 general
relativity yeah well I mean you know I
look at us as the unique species on the
planet that's able to lift ourselves up
above the timeline and think about the
past and future so that immediately
gives us at least the imaginative
capacity to travel to the past and the
future but of course you're going beyond
that you want to know about real time
travel okay that they could back then is
that time is much more individualistic
than anybody would have ever thought the
common view of time was its Universal
just same for me for you for anyone else
regardless of what we're doing what
we're experiencing how we're moving
right and that Einstein Shattered by
showing that time elapses at different
rates depending on all those qualities
right Revenue experience that's the main
new feature awesome interesting that is
amazing so now that you said that
because please one of you
um
either one of you I I'm I'm filthy with
physicists right now I can because you
just you just it's raining
[Laughter]
so this is um just um just wonderful
every time I think about it but
um if something is let's say let's go as
close as geosynchronous orbit like a
satellite and it's traveling at this
speed and they have to uh adjust the
clocks because time is ticking
differently for that thing up there than
it is for us down here and can you
please just speak to that and can you
speak to
is it a literal elapsed difference yeah
like running clock running clock or is
it something that causes it to seem like
um why shouldn't jump in maybe Neil
wants to take this but so why don't I
I'll just start with 1905 and you take
pick us up at 1916 okay so what we
learned in with 1905 special relativity
is that the faster you go all right you
will perceive events around you as
well okay
if you watch someone go fast you will
perceive their click tick and clock to
move more slowly than yourself and we
call the special theory of relativity
because it it only involved motion that
did not accelerate it was very sort of a
basic case of motion and so once she got
used to that then then 10 years later he
throws in a whole other uh fact and
Brian pick it up from there yeah the new
fact that Neil's referring to is that
gravity also affects a passage of time
so Chuck an example that you gave if you
have a clock on planet
and a clock that's hovering above the
Earth some number of miles up there
those clocks will really take off time
at different rates because they are
experiencing different forces of gravity
the stronger the pull of gravity the
slower the clock ticks so the clock on
Earth truly is ticking off time at a
slower rate than the clock that's
floating up there in space
well so what's interesting there is that
the geosynchronous satellites because
Chuck you started this by saying they
have whatever is their orbital speed
which has some significance right it's a
few miles per second really right and up
at sort of middle uh you know Ryan every
time I talk about you know there's Leo
low earth orbit and Geo but Middle Earth
orbit you know Mio every time I say
Middle Earth people are thinking Lord of
the Rings
oh don't worry Mr Frodo
look at that traffic satellite fixed sir
we'll do it
so so Brian uh so did you have you done
the math yet since you are professor of
freaking mathematics on the
geosynchronous satellites there's their
moving fast relative to us so their time
should
we should see their time slow down yeah
but they're farther away from Earth's
gravity
so that we should see their time speed
up so there's some contest between the
two there is and I don't know the exact
numbers in that particular case but I do
know that when they tested these ideas
on a Pan Am jet in the 1970s where they
had the atomic clock that they left on
the tarmac and the other they strapped
into the passenger seat maybe it's first
class I don't know
in that particular case it is the
speeding up of time from the
gravitational difference that wins out
so whenever I teach this I'm always
careful with my language because you
would think that clock should tick up
timer slowly because it's in motion but
when you take the competition into
effect in the end the net changes now
what you would have anticipated but none
of that really matters what really
matters is when you take all the effects
into account motion and gravity that
Einstein delineated the prediction
increased with the observation spot on
and so these effects are truly real so I
didn't know about that experiment and
and Brian please tell everyone hateful
hateful and Keating were the two uh two
signs okay tell everyone what Pan Am is
yeah
I'm just saying that was the southwest
of its day you know yeah
yeah kids Pan Am actually was also this
the space shuttle in in 2001 A Space
Odyssey it was a Pan Am space shuttle oh
really yeah yeah going up to the space
station where there was an ATT phone and
a Howard Johnson's
um Hotel yeah it's super cool that's
very cool so so it turns out uh I so I
didn't know that about the Pan Am that's
excellent that remains true even for the
geosynchronous satellites so the fact
that they're higher above Earth winds
over the fact that they're moving fast
and so when the geosynchronous
satellites hand us our times to our cell
phones they have to be corrected knowing
that Einstein's ideas are correct which
is just freaking mind-blowing that's you
know yeah Einstein could say it in in
his on his in his armchair right and it
can happen in a physics paper but to
actually measure the stuff there's a
whole other it's totally insane it's
totally nuts it's just one other thing
Chuck for your question even if you take
gravity out of the story right you take
two clocks and you send one into space
and it turns around it comes back and
you literally compare the clock side by
side they will show different amounts of
elapsed time so it's real the clock on
Earth in that particular case will have
ticked off
than the clock that went on that round
trip Journey so in a sense the person
carrying the clock on the round trip
Journey has traveled into the future
they're seeing the Earth time then their
own watch would suggest it should be wow
and one last point about
Ebenezer Scrooge
I we he was observing
different Christmases but
the big issue for any Storyteller is
whether you can interact either with the
past or with the present that you then
have access to and so what does Einstein
say about that well he doesn't say a
whole lot about travel to the Past
because everything that he was doing if
you actually follow it through you can
move in such a way or experience a
gravitational field that allows you to
go into the future and if you're in the
future he said sure you interact with
anything that you want to interact with
it's just that you are at a later time
than your own clock would suggest but
when it comes to the past I haven't read
anything that he wrote but it's a real
conundrum that you know Back to the
Future popularized right if you go to
the Past can you change things in such a
way that might prevent your own birth
and then you're in a logical Paradox how
could that ever happen and people have
struggled with that and we can talk
about the solutions if it's relevant to
the topic here but yeah and one of those
Solutions you can interact but you're
constrained you don't have the freedom
that you would have thought you would
have had to mess things up now wait is
that constriction forced upon you like
for instance if I were trying to get rid
of my own self so I'm gonna commit I'm
going to commit suicide via time travel
right oh okay suicide via time travel so
those constrictions since I'm coming
from a place that is already set okay I
go back at my origin before my origin
I'm sorry and then I let's just stay you
know I cause my parents to hate each
other I'm doing the reverse of the movie
right and yeah they end up hating it
because you can do this without without
Bloodshed right yeah get your put your
parents in an argument at a time they
might have made love and then you're not
conceived in that moment exactly or I
just do something really nasty but not
you know like hit on my mom and she's
just like you are adorable and I'm like
yeah don't ever talk to that guy and um
before this gets too far out of
hands
I wasn't going any further slow down
Chuck yeah slow down slow down let me
just ask this so our whip then kind of
like the box of time
Force those events to happen anyway in a
different circumstance even though I
just screwed up the circumstance under
which I came into being no I wouldn't
frame it that way okay the answer that I
would give on that is that if you travel
back to an earlier moment in time before
your own birth then you were always at
that moment
there are two versions of a given moment
in time
a moment in time can't change because
what would be the parameter through
which that change would occurred have to
be time but we're talking about
individual moments so if you go to the
Past you were always part of that moment
and therefore you were always part of
the causal chain of events that resulted
in your own birth
in the time machine
he uh the character has a love interest
and he and then she crosses the street
and is hit by a by a you know by a horse
and buggy back then I guess that was a
deadly thing and then she says no wait I
can fix that he goes back in time and
like prevents her from crossing the
street leaves her and then she gets
mugged and dies from a mugging and then
she he TR he prevents the mugging in a
third time and then she dies some other
way and he figures out that her death
was something inherent in the timeline
and there's nothing he can do to change
it Brian what you're saying is what's
inherent in that timeline is you you're
not you're not an X Factor you are part
of that equation all the time that's
correct all events just are they're
unchangeable they're immutable so the
events can't change and you simply if
you go back to the past are fulfilling
the precise of events that allowed you
to exist and to go on that journey in
the first place now look I'm not saying
this is the only resolution to these
ideas because nearly the example that
you gave brings to mind another proposal
which is which is this idea of a
Multiverse where oh okay well let's
let's pause there here we're gonna take
a quick break and we're gonna come back
and we could find out what kinds of time
travel are theoretically allowed yeah
and I'd like the one where Chuck going
back in time preordained the fact that
he would be born even if his intentions
were otherwise uh nefarious or even
suicidal we'll be right back Cosmic
queries time travel Edition with Brian
Greene
we're back Cosmic queries time travel
Edition inspired by Charles Dickens
the Ghost of Christmas Past present and
future Brian Greene we got the best
person in the world to have this
conversation with Chuck and you know you
know it absolutely so so Brian in the
case where
Chuck's uh going back in time was part
of the equation that led to his birth in
the first place even if he only just
realized that let me give what an
example that I've given before but it
seems to be consistent with that okay so
I see uh so let's say we can use
tachyons which travel backwards in time
and I can send texts via tachyons and I
watch you walk down the corridor and you
slip on a banana peel and I say to
myself but Brian's my friend I don't
want him to bust his ass slipping on a
banana peel I'm gonna text him so I text
you via tachyons you get the message
before you slipped on the on the banana
peel and you look down to the message
and by looking down you don't see the
banana peel and you slip on the banana
peel so I ended up causing you to slip
on the banana peel is that the same case
that you just described with with Chuck
yeah it's a self-consistent immutable
set of events and and the text
inexplicably from your perception is
what actually causes the event that you
wanted it to prevent but it's part of
that causal Fabric and that in this
approach is the immutable quality of the
timeline wow cool so it's very cool it's
reverse Destiny
well it's Timeless Destiny so all the
events of reality just exist out there
and it perhaps is human perception that
orders them into this causal set but
they're just all out there just like all
the spaces out there in this way of
thinking about things all of time may be
out there too and so there's nothing
that can ever be changed so in in in
Kurt vonnegut's Slaughterhouse Five uh
that time travel scenario is what you're
describing right and because in it his
entire time he's picked up by aliens and
he lives in a in a cage all right an
alien Zoo but it doesn't matter to him
because he still has access to his
entire life's timeline and when he's
describing this or they describe it to
him he said when will I die you're
always dying when was I born you're
always being born when did I go to
college you're always going to college
and so the pre-existing timeline he
could just rejoin it at any point but
the the Destiny's already
pre-pre-ordained yeah and there's
something comforting there's something
comforting about that right because even
those of us who've lost parents or loved
ones in some sense they still exist at
the moment of time that they occupied
and that is an eternal unchanging
statement but Brian it takes away free
will no
so so yes this is a version of negating
free will but I am one of those people
who doesn't believe in any variety of
free will of the traditional sword so
this doesn't run afoul of my intuition
at all she's one of those okay okay see
I know we got queries Chuck we got to
get the question this is a
Brian stop tempting us yeah you might
stop tempting us yeah you shut up Brian
let's let's act like we don't have an
audience
[Laughter]
right stop being so damn interesting
let's get to our Cosmic man okay all
right let me get to the queries I'll
I'll put my stuff on the back burner
here we go uh hey this is Jay Salmon who
says or Salman I mean it's it's salmon
but salmon maybe uh he says hello Dr
Green because a photon of light has no
Mass theoretically
can't it travel both forward and
backward in time well I love that
speaking of gravity and wait a minute if
it so it moves the speed of light and if
time goes slower for you the faster you
go then photons have no time at all yeah
I think that's if they have no time why
don't who cares whether they move it
doesn't make a difference right there is
a little forward and backwards forward
there's two ways of answering this
question I think both are really
important one is from our perception
watching the photon and from our
perception you fire a photon and it
travels through space as time elapses it
goes forward in time but then you say
what about from the photons perspective
it's traveling at the speed of light and
from what Neil described earlier when
the photon looks out at the world
everything should be going infinitely
slowly
that's poetically fine the problem I
have with taking that too seriously is
and this may seem like a footnote but
it's not you're ascribing some kind of
experience to a photon
and a photon doesn't have experience it
doesn't have Consciousness it doesn't
look out at the world even though the
poetic language is useful to invoke and
so to imagine that we could travel at
the speed of light and therefore there'd
be no time and time would stop is a step
too far so when we look at the photon
it's like any other particle it travels
through space it goes forward in time if
you put yourself into the shoes of the
photon whatever that means then
poetically yes time would stop there's
no notion of the elapsing of time
there's no notion of aging from the
photons perspective whatever that
actually means
but okay so so Chuck did you you heard
that Brian castshade on the photon he
said it it has no emotions no basically
uh Brian thinks photons are stupid and
um
okay that's Brian all right all right
all right Brian we know where you're
coming from all right okay here we go
this is um hmm
I like this let's a little more
philosophical this is Tyler J Tyler says
how my time travel be policed or
regulated if it were able to happen
oh yeah because I mean think about it if
we could if you have Bad actors going
through right yeah well again you know
I'm I'm less fearful of time travel
because of the view that I hold that you
couldn't actually change anything if you
could then yeah we'd have to have the
time police around here to avoid things
happening that we didn't want to have
happen but is that the same thing as
Hawking's time travel conjecture
um well uh he's got a few conjectures so
that's exactly which one but but I think
Hawking is the chronology protection
chronology production you can't travel
to the Past because it keeps history
safe for historians right because you
know if you could travel you could
change things and it's also his
explanation for why we're not
overwhelmed with tourists from the
future if you could travel to the Past
wouldn't everybody you know from the
Future come and visit us be gawking at
you know what life was like in the 21st
century
um but you know again they could be here
looking at us right now or another
explanation which is more plausible is
in almost any time travel scenario that
has been dreamed up you can never travel
to a moment in time prior to the
construction of the first time machine
and so if the first time machine get to
be constructed that would also explain
why no one's come back here because they
can't come back here because the
machine's yet to be built
um so that's another very
straightforward way of explaining why
we're not overrun the tourists from the
future I like that one wow all right
Chuck keep going what do you have all
right let's have some fun with this one
this is Kevin the sommelier who's uh oh
we love Kevin this summer yeah we love
Kevin assembly it never sends us he
needs to give wine never gives one
remember the instructions never sends us
well no never sends Chuck wine Neo
doesn't need any wine
I've been a meal seller he don't need no
wine
okay
all right all right Kevin the semi says
uh Dr Green what Hollywood film depicts
time travel best in your estimation
um and then he says is it frequency I
don't know I don't know why he says that
but well yeah I had a brief moment in
frequency I tried to convince the
filmmakers on how the end should be done
but it could have been frequency is a
film I had never seen it or heard of it
yeah
there's a time travel element where a
father and a son are able to communicate
across 30 years yeah dead he's the
firefighter he died in a fire so the the
son tries to tell the father go left not
right in that burning building when it
happens tomorrow and he actually
actually saves him so so they do change
the future in that particular case
um so yeah there's a Multiverse way of
thinking about it but back to they
called you for advice on that are they
coming from advice and then they asked
me if I would be in it and I'm like
interviewing
Dick Cavett and Judy different time
frames and they aged me to make me look
old in one and it was the scariest thing
really I thought it would be so simple
but I don't know if you've ever done
this and they put the plaster on your
face to mold so that they can get jowls
and things on you
um feels like being buried alive but uh
excuse me Brian black don't crack so
that wouldn't be necessary that's true
I'm I'm 87. I'm 87 years old bro
yeah
right like so Brian were you in the
movie but were you in the movie where
I'm in in a television set being
interviewed in the past and another
television in the future to like set up
this time warpy thing
um
Chuck that's not his first movie he was
in in the Mimzy movie what's the name of
that movie uh the last Mimsy yeah he was
in the last minute yeah yeah before he
was in the last Mimsy interviewed as
Brian Green would they we need expertise
on this one
you're you're great in it you're like
total natural I loved it oh thank you I
appreciate that
um okay so so what's the best movie
what's the best I would say that uh
Interstellar is is probably the best one
where you have massive economy going
near a black hole time slows down when
it goes back to the ship the fellow left
is 23 years older even though mcconnie
is only like an hour older and then
Matthew McConaughey I can't remember his
name is character the movie 23 years
older
so the guy's gray yeah yeah right right
yeah it's sort of a very crazy scene but
it's accurate you know you go down to
near a black hole and you come back and
your crew members have aged decades and
you've aged an hour
um but then in a in a very poignant
moment the character sees his own
daughter much older than he is right and
she's she's in her bed as you may recall
and he kind of comes into that room so
so those are accurate features of of
Einstein's general theory of relativity
and it's not just because your buds with
Kip Thorne who was co-executive producer
on that movie
physics at Caltech it's not just because
you're friends and that's not not
because I'm friends but no doubt it was
his expertise that kept the film on
track on scientific track which is kind
of a beautiful thing it's a great man
Chuck did you Chuck did you see
Interstellar oh God yes I love it it's
one of my favorite Sci-Fi movies did you
see did you see the name of the robot
um it's the big Square robot I forget
his name
by the way was the best uh I think
depiction of a robot in a movie it's
just a block
everybody's like I am a robot no it's
just a block like here's a square that
that that that has appendages when it
wants and you know I forget his name do
you remember the name of the robot
I I do not Brian do you remember the
name robot I I'm embarrassed to say I
can't even remember the robot so I'm out
of this
okay the robot's name was Kip Kip oh yes
there you go yeah I just thought I'd
tell you it kept saying by the way Kip
Thorne of course helped Pioneer ligo
laser into foreign gravitational wave
Observatory but receive the Nobel Prize
uh was the co-recipient of it a few
years ago and he was Henry's did the
movie so we got some good people out
there nice trying to raise science
literacy of the world a few notches so
all right there it goes so good
calculations there on the time so that's
just that's just straightforward
gravitational einsteinian physics yeah
that's all that is yeah
okay so with respect very quickly
um
is actually okay
do we have are you a patreon member it
sounds like you're asking your own
question I I paid this month
um
that's how that's what Liars sound like
that is exactly what Liars sound like
and that is why I'm a terrible liar
because that's exactly what I sound like
I paid I paid
all right so wait real very quickly uh
do we have any information on the Aging
of cells
um at the speed of light or in uh in
gravitational situations that that we
might be able to attribute to time
travel yeah well everything that we're
talking about in terms of the time
slowing down or speeding up it's truly
time so any physical process whether
it's the motion of atoms or the motion
of particles in a cell or motion of
aspects of proteins carrying out
instructions giving them by DNA at all
happens at a rate dictated by how time
elapses so when we talk about time
flowing cells flowing it's everything
slowing amazing Brian just to be clear
because it's there's a point of
ambiguity here unless we say it
explicitly it's not that being in
stronger gravity has some effect on your
physiology that makes you age more
slowly right it's an actual change in
the ticking clock wow that's on your
wall that it's everything around you and
has nothing to do with the effect of
gravity the strength of the gravity on
your metabolism or anything it has to do
with the space-time
the fabric of the space-time that you're
embedded in is that a clear way to say
totally fair and so much so that even
your thoughts would slow down in a
station field and that's why you
wouldn't even notice in your local
environment that anything had changed
right everything slows down even your
thoughts so there's no obvious evidence
of it it's only when you compare time
elapsing for you
with time elapsing for somebody far away
in a different circumstance that you
recognize
things have elapsed now of course strong
gravity might still kill your ass but
that has nothing to do with the time
that's taken right amazing amazing
amazing all right Chuck keep going okay
here we go uh this is Logan Kent and
Logan says hello beloved science
professors and happy holidays from
Kansas Cities uh I'm already giddy
waiting for the episode where we get to
hear about the knowledge and theories on
the topic of time travel okay well we're
in it okay and he's hailing from both
Kansas Cities Casey MO and Casey uh
Kansas I guess okay that's the plural
there yeah right very good he says uh
if controlled backwards time travel was
possible today where do you think your
matter or information would travel and
no I'm not talking about what time do
you want to travel though the answers
are but rather if you were in a third
position third person position observing
someone travel back in time what do you
think it would look like so the time
travel itself if you were the Observer
what would you see if you were able to
observe the timeline itself
so I'd like that but also just slipped
in there Brian was some mention about
information yes and and that links to
entropy I presume so if you can tackle
both of those in the next 90 seconds
before yeah so so look I think the only
the only real way to answer that
question is to commit to a version of
time travel to the past and the version
that I find most convincing involves
wormholes
and the idea of a wormhole I think many
people know the idea it's a tunnel from
one location it's based to another
location it pays a kind of shortcut and
if you move those openings relative to
each other you put one near a black hole
again there'll be a time difference
between the two openings so now one
opening is ahead one opening is behind
so you go through the tunnel One
Direction you go to the Future you go
through the tunnel the other direction
you go to the path so what would go into
the passive look like somebody would
enter the opening of a wormhole and they
would disappear and they'd pop out the
other opening of the Wormhole at a
different place at a different time and
so in the Marvel in the Marvel Universe
where you have Doctor Strange opening
these portals he's only moving through
space he's not actually moving through
time so that's a that's a lost
storytelling element there that they
could totally do interesting things with
it seems to me yeah I mean the richness
of wormholes really arises when you have
a time difference between the two
openings I mean it's fun to have a
tunnel through space but it is
mind-blowing to have a tunnel through
time yeah and also I would add
that I think I can add correctly Brian
that as portrayed in the movie a contact
where Jody Foster goes through this we
presume as a wormhole to get to to visit
the aliens and then she returns we like
the idea that it's it's like a water
slide you know you're in this town
you're in this tube and you're you're
sliding in there but it's really just
a simple hole you step through it right
it's not some Journey isn't that correct
because they're instant they're
basically in the same place
uh they can be but you can also have
situations where the throat of the
Wormhole has some length to it and then
again it would just be traveling through
space it wouldn't be some kind of like
you say water slide or some kind of a
weird thing that was happening but uh
but you're right okay so all right so if
you're gonna do this at least and report
on it you if you're in a wormhole and
it's propped up nicely and it's safe for
you then you you just moving through
space backwards in time if the opening
of that Wormhole is near a black hole
where time is ticking more slowly than
where you came from or if it was there
for a while once you set the time
difference between the two openings you
can then move away from the black hole
because the time difference will then
persist
wow Jesus
that is
insane so Chuck in this one broadcast
you've mentioned God and Jesus together
yes this is must be a very significant
Force operating on your brain instead I
should have said father time
why don't you give us one more question
before we hit the break all righty here
we go this is Jim Kelly and Jim Kelly
says hi Dr Tyson Dr Green Dr comedy why
do physicists assume that all time
travelers are murderous patricidal
Maniacs just
I'm just kidding but how does a
hypothetical Paradox preclude the
existence of time travel
all right let's take a quick break
because I want a good answer from Brian
out of that so Brian we're going to
discuss the paradoxes and how they're
great uh circumvented when we come back
on start talk Cosmic queries time travel
Edition fully inspired by Charles
Dickens who kind of went there first
before other novelists thinking about
the Christmas past present and future ah
humbug
we're back Cosmic query's time travel
Edition with none other than Brian
Greene whose most recent book is I gotta
like read this title because it's so
inclusive Until the End of Time mind
matter and our search for meaning in an
evolving universe and you just confessed
that you put every Google search a
keyword in there so that no matter what
anyone is searching for in the universe
they land on your book that's brilliant
you've got published by noffs in 2021
and Chuck uh how do we find you on
social media Chuck Nice comic everywhere
people nice leave off the everywhere
just Chuck nice comments thank you yeah
you're right Chuck nice comment and
Brian find me ever tell us about Brian
tell us about your social media
footprint it's really only on Twitter
and it's Kathy green at B Green B be
green okay nice you can do that without
a check mark without a blue check mark
oh right there you go never had one and
now I never will I just
I heard that after Elon took over and
the check mark thing that Jesus got a
blue check
finally so Chuck we left off with a
question just give us the highlights of
it there you go Jim Kelly who basically
says this how does a hypothetical
Paradox preclude the existence of time
travel
yeah I mean I don't think it does so the
hypothetical paradoxes are you change
the past in a way that say prevents your
own existence and we already discussed
how and maybe you can't do that but the
other idea that we may brief mention of
is If instead of traveling to the Past
in your own Universe the laws of physics
demand that you go to the Past in a
parallel universe well if you prevent
your own birth in that Universe there's
no Paradox where were you born in a
different universe and so that's another
way in which you can have the freedom to
make changes to the past but not the
past of your own world the Passover and
that's what the Marvel Universe
persistently does that's how Spider-Man
can have multiple origin stories for
example that we're actually accessing a
different Universe where similar things
are happening but not uh yeah that's so
different that we don't recognize the
story that's crazy so Brian what about
information because information I don't
think it has mass does it does it travel
well information is this intangible
thing and I always hear physicists
arguing about whether we lose or gain
information every time you do something
with a black hole yeah I mean I like to
think of information as more concrete
than that description might suggest
because information is always carried by
particles can have an abstract measure
of information but if you want to look
at the motion of information it's got to
be the motion of stuff that carries that
information and to me that makes it much
more clear what's going on so with black
holes the whole question was as
radiation comes out of a black hole
which Hawking Stephen Hawking told us
will happen are the particles instead of
Louie Hawking you mean Stephen
Universe think of specifying Brian
it was Universal literally Hawking
actually was responsible
so so as the
the question is should do the particles
have a relationship among each other
that carries away the information of
what fell in so it's really concrete
when you think about it as information
carried by stuff
okay because right because because
otherwise there's no information without
stuff to carry it that's another way
it's hard to follow the information
without that commitment so so so when it
comes to like uh for those of us who are
listening that may not be so
um familiar with what you're talking
about so you when you go into a black
hole I'm a chair I go into a black hole
I get broken down into just particles
okay that's all because the gravity is
so strong now just the string of
particles I come out during the
evaporation
would I be able to be a chair again I am
okay that is the question that is the
question right and and for a while
Hawking said no that your particles
would come out and they'd have no memory
of their earlier configuration the
information that They Carried would be
lost but he was ultimately convinced by
string theorists and others that that
was wrong the particles came out and
they do carry the imprint of the fact
that they were once a chair and if you
measure the particles appropriately You
Could reconstruct the chair when those
particles come out damn
that's amazing but the chair itself
doesn't come out you have you have to
still make the chair it's not that way
it's now an Ikea chair
Ikea is in black hole Jack I love that
new Theory all right Brian I want a new
research paper
I went on my desk in the morning Brian
the Ikea hypothesis
wow that's amazing all right Chuck keep
them coming okay let's keep it going
um this is from why cause and why says
hello Brian hello Neil and then he puts
in parentheses with the question mark
Chuck okay that ain't right I don't know
what's up even Lord Chuck we've been I
know King Chuck yeah all right okay he
says is it possible to calculate
precisely where the universe uh where in
the universe Earth was in a moment to
make sure that we find ourselves on
Herb's surface and not in the position
that Earth was in
when we are time traveling how would you
compensate oh wait and then wait a
minute now this is where he gets this
way you know that why cause was either
thinking too much or maybe might have
been smoking a little something then he
goes okay then it goes like this how
would you also compensate for the
expansion of the universe when
calculating that trajectory so he's he's
getting it all in he's he's all in so so
let me let me let me talk to Brian here
after I say something so so in Back to
the Future
they kind of in the original they kind
of avoided that problem because
when Marty went back in time he went
back in time in a precise whole number
of years
okay and so Earth would be back where it
is when he goes back in time in its in
its orbit you know enough for the plot
line but if he went back a week or even
an hour he's not in that parking lot
anymore at all so so Brian tell me about
all this time travel mechanisms when in
fact the universe is changing wow so you
can't just show up in the same place and
expect to to you know to be home again
exactly right and so when you time
travel you also need to space travel
it's really space time travel right you
have to pick the location in time and
the location in space and typically in
these films they only talk about the
time part of things and to make it
concrete if you're using the Wormhole
version of time travel the opening of
The Wormhole that you're going to exit
from it's at some position in space at
some moment in time when you exit you
better be certain that you have somehow
maneuvered that open opening to be say
on planet Earth if when you exit you
want to still be on planet Earth
otherwise you could exit back in time
but near the Andromeda galaxy or just an
empty space so you do need to dial both
in in order to get to where you are
intending okay interesting I bet they
don't know that but we accept it anyway
right as a sure as it's implicit it's
implicit I guess uh is what that is
Chuck keep them coming all right let's
go I I want to find this young person
the way you the way you you described
that previous question it sounds like we
should have a cosmic queries only if the
people were on weed when they wrote the
question oh man let me tell you
something that's a great show
um
just legal weed not illegal it will
either be our best show or our worst
show or the worst no no it'll while
we're doing it we'll think it's the best
right and then afterwards we'll know
it's the worst exactly and that is kind
of how that goes all right this is
Savage 162 and Savage 162 says in the
frontier of science is there any idea on
how to try and detect the theorize
tachyon particle
so remind us what attacking on is Brian
yeah so it's what you had mentioned
earlier and you know this idea of a
particle that can go faster than the
speed of light and when a particle can
go hypothetical I should say a particle
goes faster the speed of light there are
observers watching that particle who
will see it reach its Target before it
was emitted by The Source reach its
Target before it was emitted by the
source so cause and effect become
flipped for The Observers who are
witnessing the motion of attacking on
um so the question is how would you ever
detect these things
um yeah and and it's it's a bit first of
all you know to measure something going
faster than the speed of light that's
actually not that hard you start with a
particle at one location and you fire it
and you simply calculate or you measure
I should say how long it took to get to
the Target did it Be The Light Beam or
not and that's it so so that's pretty
straightforward and indeed you may
recall I don't know some 10 years ago
that neutrino thing yeah right yeah
there's in Italy there was a claim that
these neutrinos had gone from the source
to the Target and beaten a beam of light
they'd gotten there earlier than a beam
of light would now some of us knew that
could Brian you know the joke about that
the Euro joke because Europeans like
joking about each other they said that
would have been the first time Italy
arrived anywhere early yeah that's right
right that's that's exactly right so
that that was that was the key tip off
immediately that nothing
but but scientifically
fascinating would have been fascinating
would have been an example of something
going past the speed of light and so
people looked really intently at the
data and ultimately realized that there
was some kind of loose wire or fiber
optic cable or something I can't
remember the details and when that was
repaired the particles did not go faster
than the speed of light but in principle
but let me add Brian because you might
not go go there and for the benefit of
Chuck that in my field and it surely
happens in your field somebody gets a
cockamamie uh observation which would
later be shown to be wrong but if it's
right it's amazing and you have these
ambulance chasing theorists coming up
with an explanation of of course why
that must be so did that happen in the
case of the neutrinos oh gosh you know
I'm not completely sure there must have
been a few papers because nobody could
have fully resisted it within the
confines of the entire field but 99 of
the people who encounter that result
that I spoke they were like it can't be
true it just can't be true and it wasn't
true here we go Ryan this is just Ryan
he's like Cher Just Ryan he says uh
hello doctors if we developed a way to
time travel backwards
could we travel to a time before the Big
Bang or would we just break science
altogether
I love it Brian yeah well the whole
question before the Big Bang is is a
deep one and it could simply be that
there's no notion of before when it
comes to the Big Bang because the Big
Bang could be the origin of time itself
and so the notion of before makes sense
when you're talking about you know 1800s
or 2000 BC or whatever but when you get
to the beginning of time itself there's
simply no conception of before and so
there may not even be a realm of reality
that we could delineate as before the
Big Bang
right this is the same I think I've
heard Hawking this is Louis Hawking told
me yes
might be like asking what's north of the
North Pole yeah that's a good example is
defined there yeah and you can't once
you're as far north as you can go you
can't go farther north once you're as
far back in time at the beginning you
can't go further back yeah and I should
say that that's only one idea it's an
interesting and provocative one but
there are other approaches which suggest
that there is a realm before the Big
Bang right maybe many Big Bangs giving
rise to many universes and our bang may
not have been in any sense the first
right and so there may be around you'd
have to pass out of our sort of
space-time structure and enter somebody
else's space-time if you want to go
before what happened with the big bang
yeah that's right you have a subway line
yeah you you reach the end of one line I
mean you can't go any further that's it
but you can switch to another Subway and
then you can go on from there but you're
in a different thing at that point
different training you're different you
don't have to pay another fare in this
version
and and Chuck the laws of physics might
be a little different so that your body
would right fall into a pile of goo
yeah
so Brian it's supposed to get for a dump
of the Turn Style
oh oh Brian just close this out if you
could what kind of time travel did in
all of your variants did Charles Dickens
invoke for Christmas past and future it
sort of feels like a worm holy version
where they're traveling through a
wormhole to the past and maybe they're
just hovering at the edge of the
Wormhole not actually entering that
reality and if we're not interacting
with it yeah therefore they're sort of
more in an observer status as opposed to
a participant status it kind of
resonates with that but you know but
don't you need a different Universe now
because there were some different
outcomes right so now there's that's
right and and so this would be an
example where the Wormhole stretches
from one Universe to another as opposed
to from one universe same universe yeah
but the but the different outcomes were
not uh directly attributable to the time
travel that different different outcomes
were because of his change of actions in
the present which affected the future
that's right so the past never changed
yeah I think yeah
the past was oh my gosh is that what the
future is going to be no it's not right
because I'm going to change myself in
the present yeah yeah exactly yeah so
the basic idea is Imagine three or some
number of tunnels emanating from this
realm to these other parallel universes
sort of like slices of bread and a grand
Cosmic reality or each slice of bread is
its own universe so you just have these
tunnels connecting us to them allowing
you to witness what would happen in a
world where things were different
wow damn
it's amazing all right we gotta let's we
gotta land that plane right there Brian
it's been a delight to have you back on
Star Talk
um always a pleasure
uh it's really you're just up the street
we should have you on even we should be
like a regular Brian a feature right uh
give Brian his own admit a minute two
minutes no you're making whatever he was
called Brian time Brian time
guys uh great to have you Chuck always
good to have you there always a pleasure
for these uh Cosmic queries I I am Neil
deGrasse Tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist as always I bid you
[ __ ]
up
[Music]